20,000 AND 20,000 AND THE BAD
PEOPLE DON'T SHARE INFORMATION
WITH THEM.
>> Martha: THANKS.
LET'S BRING IN TOMI LAHREN AND
GERALDO RIVERA, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTORS AT LARGE.
THIS IS A HORRIFIC SITUATION.
EVERY WEEKEND WE SEE MORE
SHOOTINGS ACROSS THE NATION.
SO TODAY, MOMENTS AGO IN THE
WHITE HOUSE BRIEFING ROOM, JEN
PSAKI WAS ASKED WHAT IS THE
PRESIDENT'S REACTION TO THIS.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO GET AHEAD OF
HIS COMMENTS OR REMARKS LATER
THIS WEEK.
IT IS AN AREA WHERE THE
PRESIDENT FEELS A GREAT DEAL OF
THE CRIME WE'RE SEEING AS A
RESULT OF GUN VIOLENCE, YOU CAN
EXPECT HE WILL SPEAK TO THAT AND
HIS COMMITMENT TO CONTINUING TO
ADDRESS GUN VIOLENCE AND GUN
SAFETY IN THE COUNTRY.
>> Sandra:
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO APPARENTLY WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR SOMETHING FROM THE
PRESIDENT ON THIS.
I WOULD MENTION BEFORE GOING TO
YOU BOTH, KEISHA BOTTOMS THE
MAYOR IN ATLANTA SAID IT'S
PROBABLY A COVID REOPENING
PROBLEM.
SHE SAID HER CITY OPENED TOO
SOON AND THAT'S THE REASON
THEY'RE SEEING SO MUCH CRIME.
TOMI, WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> HOW BLISSFULLY IGNORANT ARE
THESE DEMOCRATS?
THEY BLAME THE SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS, LAW ABIDING AMERICANS
GOING AFTER GUN CONTROL, TALKING
ANT GUNS.
THEN THEY GO AFTER A REOPENING
ALLOWING BUSINESSES AND PEOPLE
TO GO ON AND LIVE THEIR NORMAL
LIVES.
THEY BLAME THOSE TWO FACTORS?
THEY DON'T BLAME THE DEFUND THE
POLICE MOVEMENT THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE BEEN PLACATING THE LAST
1 1/2 YEARS IN THESE CITIES LED
BY DEMOCRATS?
THEY HAVE DEFUNDED OR
REALLOCATED OR SHORTING THEIR
POLICE DEPARTMENTS.
THAT'S WHERE YOU SEE HOMICIDES
RISE AND A CULTURE OF
LAWLESSNESS.
THERE'S A CERTAIN SEGMENT OF
AMERICANS THAT HAVE WATCHED THIS
UNFOLD.
THEY KNOW THERE'S NO
CONSEQUENCES IF THEY EXIST AT
ALL, THEY'LL BE SMALL
CONSEQUENCES.
IN NEW YORK CITY LOOTERS NOT
BEING CHARGED AFTER WHAT
HAPPENED LAST SUMMER.
THE MESSAGE IS BEING SENT OUT.
THE POLICE ARE OUTNUMBERED.
THEY CAN'T DO ANYTHING TO YOU IF
YOU ARE CAUGHT IN YOUR CRIME.
SO THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE
INMATES RUN THE PRISON.
>> Martha: GERALDO, IT DOES FEEL
LIKE THAT.
FEELS LIKE IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF
A NO-GO ZONE IN SOME OF THESE
PLACES.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON IN
WASHINGTON SQUARE PARK IN
NEW YORK.
LET'S PUT UP THE PICTURE OF THE
TWO DAs.
YOU HAVE DARCEL CLARK IN THE
BRONX AND CYRUS VANCE JR. WHO IS
FOCUSING HIS CHARGES AGAINST
TRUMP AND TAX CHARGES.
THEY SAY WE'RE NOT GOING TO
PROSECUTE IN THE RIOTS IN NEW
YORK CITY WHERE PEOPLE BROKE THE
WINDOWS, TOOK MERCHANDISE OUT,
RAN WITH IT.
THEY STOLE CARS AND DROVE THEM
ALL AROUND THE CITY.
YOU KNOW, PERPETRATED MORE
CRIME.
LISTEN TO THIS.
THIS IS JESSICA BETANCOURT.
SHE'S A BUSINESS OWNER.
>> IT DISGUSTING, OUTRAGEOUS THE
WAY WE GET TREATED.
NOBODY MADE AN EFFORT TO COME TO
THE STORES AND SAY, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
CAN I GET SOME SURVEILLANCE, CAN
I GET SOME FINGERPRINTING TO SEE
IF WE COULD CATCH THESE LOOSERS.
NO EFFORTS WERE MADE BY THE
CITY.
>> Martha: NO EFFORTS MADE BY
THE CITY TO PROSECUTE ANY OF
THESE 400-SOME PEOPLE, GERALDO.
>> MARTHA THAT IS THE OFFICE
WHERE I BEGAN MY LEGAL CAREER.
MY DAUGHTER FOLLOWED ME IN THAT
NEW YORK DA'S OFFICE.
YOU KNOW, THEY SAY THEY'RE
OVERWHELMED WITH COVID CAUSES
BECAUSE THE COURTS WERE CLOSED.
YET THEY'RE STILL INVESTIGATING
TRUMP ON THESE LAME TAX CHARGES.
THEY'RE DROPPING OTHER CHARGES
AGAINST THE 2020 LOOTERS.
WHY ARE THEY DROPPING THE
CHARGES?
BECAUSE THE KIDS THAT STOLE AND
BURNED WERE PROTESTING THE DEATH
OF GEORGE FLOYD.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY BALONEY.
YOU CAN'T PICK AND CHOOSE.
LAWS MUST BE UPHELD EQUALLY.
SHAME ON THE GROWNUPS THAT
JUSTIFY LAWLESSNESS.
THOSE WERE NOT PROTESTERS.
THEY'RE CROOKS.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THESE DEATHS, A
GHETTO CIVIL WAR.
IT'S A CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE OF OUR
TIME.
>> Martha: IF YOU DON'T
PROSECUTE THESE CRIMES, IT SENDS
THE MESSAGE THAT IT'S OKAY,
RIGHT?
YOU CAN DO IT.
YOU THE DO WHOEVER YOU WANT.
YOU LOOK AT A DIFFERENT LEVEL.
A MAYOR'S RACE HERE IN
WASHINGTON SQUARE PARK.
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S AN
INDICATION THAT ANYBODY HAS A
SPINE TO CRACK DOWN ON THIS.
PEOPLE ARE HANGING IT OUT IN
WASHINGTON SQUARE PARK AND SAID
THAT WE WILL BE HERE EVERY DAY.
THEY SAID THIS IS AS MUCH OUR
HOME AS IT IS OTHER RESIDENTS
HAVE TO LIVE HERE.
IF YOU CAN'T ACCEPT THE FACT IF
I'M LIVING WITHIN MY
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS, YOU'RE
LIVING IN THE COUNTRY AND
DEMOCRACY IS NOT FOR YOU.
THEY TRIED CURFEWS IN THE PARK,
TOMI.
NONE OF THAT HAS WORKED TO
RESTORE PEACEFUL ENVIRONMENT IN
THIS PART OF NEW YORK.
THEY HAVE FREE REIGN.
>> THIS IS NOT JUST THE DEFUND
THE POLICE MOVEMENT.
THIS IS ALSO CAN BE ATTRIBUTED
TO A LOT OF THE POLICIES ON THE
BOOK, THE BAD PUBLIC POLICIES.
YOU HAVE FELON CODDLING
PROSECUTORS, CASHLESS BAIL,
REDUCED SENTENCING, PEOPLE SAY I
CAN DO WHATEVER I WANT.
ADD ON TO THAT, PASS IT OFF AS
JUSTICE OR GET OUT OF JAIL FREE
CARD IF YOU SAY YOU'RE BEING
OPPRESSED OR BEING IN SOME WAY
THIS IS A PRODUCT OF RACISM,
THEN YOU FEEL LIKE YOU CAN DO
WHATEVER YOU WANT.
IT'S NOT JUST IN ROUGH CITIES,
THIS IS HAPPENING IN ATLANTA,
BUCKHEAD.
THIS IS COMING TO A CITY A
SUBURB NEAR YOU.
PEOPLE WILL START TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE WHEN SOCIAL
MEDIA HASHTAGS ARE PUBLIC
POLICY.
IT'S DANGEROUS AND RECKLESS.
>> Martha: I WANT TO FINISH AND
GET A LAST THOUGHT FROM YOU,
GERALDO, THIS IS JAMES CRAIG,
THE FORMER DETROIT POLICE CHIEF
ON SUNDAY MORNING WITH MARIA.
WATCH THIS.
>> OUR PROFESSION IS IN A CRISIS
RIGHT NOW.
SOME OF THE MAYORS IN THESE
CITIES ARE FAILING MISERABLE.
LOOK AT CHICAGO.
LORI LIGHTFOOT TALKS ABOUT WHAT
IS DANGEROUS.
COPS ARE DANGEROUS?
NO, SHE'S DANGEROUS.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THE FAILED
LEADERSHIP.
WHERE IS THE SUPPORT FOR THE MEN
AND WOMEN?
THIS ANTI-POLICE RHETORIC.
IT'S NOT A SURPRISE THEY'RE
LEAVING.
>> Martha: THE SUPPORT FOR THE
BLUE IS GONE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHORT GREAT
SUPPORT FOR THE LAW ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND TRAGIC INCIDENCES
THAT HAVE HAPPENED.
WHAT DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT
BIDEN NEEDS TO SAY TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THIS COUNTRY?
>> THAT DEFUND THE POLICE WAS
THE STUPIDEST SOCIAL MOVEMENT OF
OUR TIME.
TO TAKE THE GUNS OUT OF THE
HANDS OF THE COPS OR TO TAKE
THEIR COMMUNITY SUPPORT AWAY IS
APPALLING.
YOU HAVE NOW THE OPPOSITE THAT
IS HAPPENING.
I SEE, MARTHA, A COMEBACK.
THE CLASS, THE RECRUITMENT CLASS
AND THE POLICE ACADEMY NOW, OVER
14,000.
IT'S A RECORD.
MANY MINORITIES ARE SIGNING UP.
THE COMMUNITY IS COMING BACK TO
THE COPS.
ERIC ADAMS, THE FORMER POLICE
CAPTAIN IS THE LEADING
CANDIDATE.
PEOPLE HAVE GONE FROM DEFUND THE
POLICE TO SUPPORT THE POLICE AND
LAW AND ORDER IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE OF THIS TIME.
>> Martha: I HOPE YOU'RE RIGHT
FOR THIS CITY AND FOR CITIES
ACROSS THE NATION.
BECAUSE IT'S OUT OF CONTROL.
THANK GOD THE TWO KIDS ARE OKAY.
I THINK THAT THAT IMAGE SHOULD
STAY IN EVERYBODY'S MIND ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY ABOUT HOW RAMPANT
AND HOW PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY